[Music]
marching to their own beat catalonia's
youth the latest to take to the streets
in huge demonstrations demanding the
right to vote Spanish government too
many Catalans so the referendum is
illegal and unconstitutional but calls
supporting it on the streets have only
become louder you know actually against
the will of Spain central government if
they get away with that it is a direct
challenge not only to Spain's national
unity the unity of Europe as a whole
that makes the stakes here very high
lines are being drawn Madrid's ordered
the region's police to stop the
referendum if they don't
thousands of national police are on
standby in cruise ships in Barcelona's
harbour to be deployed across Catalonia
to shut down the vote we went to the
town of Rennes de menthe to meet its
mayor who's been warned by the courts he
faces prosecution if he lets the vote
happen he will be used next Sunday as a
poly gas station but he says he's
determined to keep its polling stations
open in defiance of Madrid I just can
say that everything is ready and that in
Sunday morning the free voting gas
station will be ready but if the police
come and shut down the polling stations
or take the bell voices what happens
we will try to start again after the
police left are you prepared to go to
jail for this
I prefer don't think about I believe in
democracy I prefer to be honest with my
commitment with with my neighbors and
with my government but if it comes to it
will you go to jail well tensions are
mounting the fear is of unrest following
a yes vote and say legal experts a
constitutional crisis testing Spain's
national unity like never before
how bad do you think it could get any
country can be destroyed in a moment we
have seen that before
so I think that for a spring is very
very serious and I'm sorry to say that I
I I would like to have another point of
view but I must be honest I think that
the the problem is very severe
the referendum divides Catalans down the
middle poll suggests half of them want
independence the other half don't
they're demonstrating - I've been born
in Barcelona raised in Barcelona my
family has been you astonish industry
forever
I knew she difference between me and
anyone from Madrid but you don't want
Catalan independence I don't I think it
would be better all together
Uncle Mo I love from Spain I don't want
to be another country opponents of the
referendum aren't campaigning or voting
so a yes vote seems certain and the
Catalan government plans on declaring
independence 48 hours later the stage is
set for a showdown between Catalonia and
Madrid with independence movements
across Europe watching and plotting
their next move
Dominic Waghorn Sky News Barcelona